on vous remercie beaucoup
lassival du bar de d'être avec nous la
délégation du Conseil est générale de la
Réunion dans les salons de bofranc à la
présidence du Sénat le lieu est
prestigieux le prix également les Rubans
du développement durable depuis 10 ans
l'initiative lancée notamment par
l'Association des maires de France
récompense des collectivités locales
pour leur engagement cette année le
département de la réunion a été choisi
comme une dizaine d'autres collectivités
une reconnaissance nationale pour les
actions de développement durable dans
chacune des politiques du conseil
général les Rubans du développement
durable étaient un prix nationalement
connu et qui
est donné par un jury autonome le
président est un philosophe et donc je
crois que c'est une récompense qui au
fond doit être dédié à l'ensemble bien
évidemment des agents qui ont travaillé
au niveau du conseil général mais j'ai
envie de dire c'est le prix de chaque
réunionnais je dédie donc ce prix à tous
les Réunionnais parce que nous sommes un
le département
l'éducation à la culture
environnementale à la culture écologique
et capitales pour que nous préservions
et nous valorisons ce beau patrimoine
qui est le note qui est aujourd'hui
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
la majorité de ces jeunes nous les avons
mis sur des chantiers d'insertion en les
mettant en activité pour travailler dans
les hauts de l'île préserver l'existant
alors mieux qu'un discours je vous
invite tous vraiment à venir voir
qu'est-ce que c'est que la durabilité
chez nous à l'île de la Réunion une
invitation au voyage largement applaudie
parmi les invités au Sénat qui ont
accueilli avec de larges sourires la
présentation faite par la délégation
réunionnaise dans la candidature le
département a mis en avant les efforts
portés sur le jardin de l'État se des
agriculteurs avec la diversification des
cultures l'artisanat avec la filière
bois de goyavier et tous les projets en
faveur des hauts protéger le patrimoine
naturel en favorisant l'insertion c'est
l'un des aspects qui le gérer des
actions à l'échelle locale elles sont
quasiment pratiquement les seuls
aujourd'hui qui prennent vraiment au
sérieux certains aspects de ce qu'on
appelle la durabilité pour la Réunion
c'est l'histoire des sentiers et puis si
vous voulez le mariage environnement
social qui nous a beaucoup intéressé oui
c'est collectivités sont attentives aux
enjeux du monde contemporain oui elles
sont réactives aux attentes nouvelles de
leur concitoyens le président du Sénat
Jean-Pierre Bel a rappelé le rôle
fondamental des collectivités locales
une politique sur le long terme pour le
Conseil Général de la réunion avec les
Rubans du développement durable c'est le
troisième prix que reçoit le département
pour son action dans le domaine